savez dans la dans l'inversion de la
contractualisation là nous avons un cas
d'école particulier avec le beurre
d'abord il n'y a pas de pénurie de
beurre s'il a pu manquer du beurre dans
les magasins c'est parce que il ya eu
des achats de précaution beaucoup
d'achats de précaution qui ce sont les
consommateurs les consommateurs et bien
au lieu d'acheter une plaquette de
beurre comme il en avait l'habitude les
ont achetés par quatre ou cinq
et moi je dis aux gens de ne pas stocker
en plus le beurre quand il est mis au
congélateur c'est pas c'est pas la
meilleure manière de le conserver et de
le manger et de le déguster après c'est
un normand qui vous le dit mais ce que
je veux dire c'est que sur le beurre
nous avons demandé à ce que chacun
prenne ses responsabilités les
distributeurs prennent leur
responsabilité je sais qu'il ya des
discussions en cours
ce sont des discussions qui ne sont pas
toujours qui ne sont pas toujours facile
mais je crois que nous allons arriver à
un point de sortie parce que c'est
nécessaire et moi j'y mets tout mon
poids politique là dedans parce que le
ministère de la culture il est là aussi
moteur pour inciter les uns et les
autres à trouver les voies du compromis
et nous avons besoin de trouver sa voie
de compromis et je puis vous dire que ne
manqueront pas de beurre et un certain
nombre de grands de grandes surfaces et
de groupes de la distribution ont déjà
passé des trades des trains de hausse
ont accepté du moins il est train de
hausses des transformateurs donc je ne
vois pas pourquoi
demain les rayons ne serait pas regard
de ce problème